there is a democratic debate tonight on
NBC and MSNBC it's a partnership debate
with the Nevada independent this is just
a few days before the third primary of
2020 which is the Nevada caucus on
Saturday now as far as who will be
participating remember that we
speculated the DNC might do this and
they did at the end of January the DNC
said we have no more individual donor
requirement to qualify for the debates
this was very obviously a change that
had the potential to allow Michael
Bloomberg into the debates and it has
worked to allow Michael Bloomberg into
the debates I told you yesterday that
because of Michael Bloomberg being in
second place nationally in the latest
NPR PBS Marist Poll Michael Bloomberg
has qualified for tonight's debate and
very quickly the narrative is becoming
Ernie versus Bloomberg the anti
billionaire or billionaire as Bernie
likes to say against the uber
billionaire because Michael Bloomberg
far wealthier than Tom Steyer far
wealthier than Donald Trump now very
often the narratives that the that we
are told about the stories we are told
about these debates are completely fake
and fabricated I remember that I think
it was between the first and second
democratic debate where we still had
like 12 people on the stage somebody
some network CNN or whoever was running
that second debate promoted tonight beto
versus booted judge or whatever you know
some fake story that no one actually
cared about tonight the implications are
actually huge in terms of who goes up
against whom what sort of battles and
enclaves and cliques start to develop
because there's a few possibilities for
tonight does tonight become a with
Bernie as now the leader in just about
every recent national poll and Michael
Bloomberg at his first debate does
tonight become Bernie versus Bloomberg
with debates about about billionaires
and fairness and stop-and-frisk or
whatever else is that the primary story
tonight or does tonight become everybody
gangs up on Bernie in other words the
establishment
that it's Biden Budaj Klobuchar maybe
even Bloomberg do they all gang up on
Bernie to try to hurt him or do the
establishment centrists recognize that
the greatest threat to them is actually
the introduction of Bloomberg and maybe
the DNC saying Biden's crashing we don't
want Peter Amy let's go with Michael
Bloomberg so do the establishment
centrist tonight
not go after Bernie but instead focus on
Michael Bloomberg we don't know the
participants tonight are Pete Buddha
judge Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren
Amy Klobuchar Joe Biden and Michael
Bloomberg so we will see what dynamics
develop there and it could go a few
different ways and in fact if Michael
Bloomberg continues to gain polling
support the DNC is going to have to make
a decision will the DNC see Bloomberg as
a possible Savior from the declining
Biden and an Amy Klobuchar who has some
support but doesn't seem like really
enough to get the nomination and the
Budaj edge who while he did well in Iowa
and New Hampshire lacks experience what
is the DNC going to do so will the DNC
shift from Biden to somebody else and if
so who will they shift to again
Bloomberg in second place nationally now
in some polls third in an average of
recent polls what is his future going to
be
after presumably winning some delegates
on Super Tuesday and meanwhile if you
are the establishment do you go all-in
on Bloomberg or ignore him altogether
that is a really significant decision
that the DNC establishment needs to make
because it's going to set the tone for
whatever strategy they are going to
employ to try to deny Bernie the
nomination between now and the
convention remember Tom Steyer is a
billionaire but far less wealthy than
Bloomberg far less prominent than
Bloomberg never really polling much at
all with Bloomberg now in the picture we
have the possibility of Bernie and
Bloomberg squaring off on exactly the
policies that Bernie would push which
would cost Michael Bloomberg a lot of
money well anybody call Michael
Bloomberg
by the way regarding the recent audio
publicized of Bloomberg saying horrible
things about black men and stop and
frisk or is that going to be ignored in
tonight's debate will there be a
question about that from the moderators
Bernie said at his rally Monday night
that Bloomberg will not be allowed to
buy this election and it would be very
interesting to see that confrontation
and that topic come up firsthand I hope
you will join me live for a debate
pre-show starting probably around 8:15
p.m. Eastern time tonight will do about
45 minutes of pre-show at the top of the
hour we will go to live debate coverage
we will be on YouTube and twitch for the
pre-show
debate itself probably just on twitch
and then back on both YouTube and twitch
for the post debate analysis join me
there let me know what you expect in
tonight's debate via Twitter I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman follow me and let me
know what you're expecting in tonight's
debate